because i had a tough year you know i
lost my dad in october
oh wow yeah not through covey i think i
was like
but but he uh he passed away you know
stroke and it was sudden
and you know i've have i'm having to
deal that with my family at the moment
and you know it's to the point that it
kind of clouded my
what's the meaning of life what am i
doing what the hell am i doing you know
grief messes with you and it wasn't uh
so this is like my first venture out
back to the studio back to like
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we have a very
very special guest today i've actually
been listening to her music
for damn near over a decade now wow and
so
you know when i when i followed you
because i don't really follow that many
people on instagram because i don't use
the platform that much
and uh i remember i started following
you messaged me i was like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] melissa polanar is [ __ ]
messaging me that's crazy
because i just i don't really like i'm
on instagram but not as much right
if you look at my page it looks like
trash there's no theme it looks like
somebody's grandma is running their page
which is my [ __ ] you know so when i uh
when i followed you because i
for some reason doesn't connect that the
people that i listen to i don't really
follow them on instagram i don't know
why
i don't i don't necessarily follow
everybody that i listen to as well
i don't really keep track i think we're
not a part of that generation where
it's like almost customary that you do
yeah and if you don't it's actually
offensive and i didn't know about that
[ __ ]
like people are like oh how come you're
not following me it's like am i supposed
to like do i have to like
we're talking we're having a
conversation so i thought it was fine
but i remember i saw your stuff and
years ago when you first started when i
first saw you it was i can't even
remember the name of the song but i just
know
that when i heard it your boy started
tearing up oh i i was in bed and i just
had
tear drops go into my eardrums
you ever crying to your [ __ ] earlobes
like oh [ __ ] oh sensitive
guy i think it was the first song that
you did that kind of blew up it was you
would just was it meant to be
was it a love song it was a love song so
i'll bring it also
right now there's there's two i think
that
there was two that blew up but the one
that i tried meant to be it was try
oh so like there's nothing nothing i
can't yes
yeah i was like what is this who is this
angel oh
this it was probably probably till this
day is probably you know what i like too
it's it was original music
and at that time and even still till
this day everybody only does covers
and so when i saw a singer songwriter it
blew my [ __ ] mind
yeah well there is a history to that um
before youtube even happened for me
i was signed as a songwriter in
nashville under like a warner chapel
oh [ __ ] well that [ __ ] makes sense
then
okay so i was you know i'm i was raised
in texas
but i was always been i've always been
musical growing up you know i was in
choir i was in orchestra
i was in band i was that geek musical
geek
um and also too i think music kind of is
a form of my communication i'm pretty
introverted into you know very reserved
and
i basically made friends because of
music so i just kind of
did that kept doing that so people will
come to me
you know it's it's one of those things
that where you know sometimes they don't
know how to talk to me but when i
sing upfront or play or perform it's
like that's when
people gravitate to me and like i
actually make relationships that way
yeah you know from friends and
whatever so i guess through
like i think junior year senior year
i went you know i would do gigs in the
summer just because i was
very motivated to just do shows on my
own and one time i just did a
coffeehouse show and
some executive found me wow
yeah and i i i was even like unsure it's
like can i trust this dude
like well of course some random guy
comes up you have talent
come meet me in the back room hold on a
second yeah
so i gave him like my demo that my
brother and i kind of recorded in his
bedroom like it was really like not
sophisticated at all i just gave him my
contact and all that stuff and
i went back home and then i got a phone
call and said like hey
we're from warner chapel and we want to
invite you to nashville
and this was teenage you know teenage
years yeah
and my family
i didn't grow up with a mommager and a
dadar it's just like me
just driven by the love of music so
one thing led to another started
negotiating a publishing deal which is
basically i didn't even know existed
which is song writing
you write songs for a living literally
yeah um the purpose was to
um develop me as an
artist but they didn't know what to do
with me oh cause
asian from texas sings soulful
playing the guitar and piano like what
the hell do we do with this girl
yeah and this was you know you got to
keep in mind this was before social
media
this was before youtube uh shortly
before youtube and stuff
so but i was naive i thought it was like
well if they like my talent they're just
gonna love my music
but industry doesn't work that way
they're gonna look at you
and like assess your value pretty much
yeah
so fortunately for me i had a few people
who believed in what i did
but didn't quite know what to do they
still signed me to a publishing deal
which is basically songwriting
yeah so it's not a not a record deal
okay so record deal is basically you
record and they will market you whatever
the hell they
they have a whole budget behind you to
market you as an artist yeah so
publishing deal is more of like
just songwriting not just it's a big
deal but it's
it's songwriting but kind of like the
implied purpose of
developing me as an artist whatever that
may be
um long story short couple years in my
boss or my creative directors left
it was like a revolving door of ceo
which happens a lot
a lot so here i was very you know naive
and like i moved to nashville briefly
because i was wanting to do it 100
and i did it kind of like against my
family's wishes because obviously they
wanted me to become a nurse
oh of course of course
yeah so i kind of i wasn't really a
rebellious kid growing up but then that
was kind of like my subtle like
veering off into my own path decision
um yeah and so um i was heartbroken that
was like
i keep telling people that my first
heartbreak wasn't a dude
my first heartbreak was music industry
that's crazy
yeah i i went back home to texas after
like
everything fell through like everybody
left in the company new people
took over and they didn't believe in
what i did or just
didn't see anything viable in my
artistry
i went back home kind of went back to
college took all these
you know went back for um pr advertising
okay just for the sake of finishing um
a college degree to appease my family
and
uh and then youtube started to happen
that was
the that was so youtube was kind of like
my reincarnation in a way
yeah that's pretty nuts because your
your skill level
preceded what most people have when they
would do their first video
yeah you don't see that and so when i
when i listen to that song who the [ __ ]
is this
i was like how did you write this well
it's interesting because i did see the
pattern of like
you know asian american artists who do a
lot of covers right and the thing is
i at that point i was i already had like
a catalog of songs that i'm like
why am i gonna cover other people's
songs when i have these songs i know
it's
the less the least or less popular thing
to do but
that was kind of what drove me to share
more original stuff
yeah and so actually the first song that
i shared was meant to be
that was like the wedding song that
still to this day a lot of people still
sing on their weddings well that's the
thing about your music though it's like
i i always gave a lot of [ __ ] to a lot
of like youtube musicians right
because the title of musician is very
very important to me when i hear that
type of [ __ ] and i just had
hold on a second people calling me up
and saying you're crazy we on a podcast
but there was that title of being a
musician but none of them
could really create their own music
right and not to say that every artist
does
but you know on top of that they
wouldn't have written original music
whether somebody else did or they did it
for themselves and so
hearing somebody create their own music
which was really [ __ ] good and your
[ __ ] was like radio ready
you know thank you she's very odd
because i know listen you know who the
[ __ ] you are
youtubers when you put out your original
that you wrote yourself i really wish
you never wrote it yourself because
terrible so you should have got somebody
else because they think it's easy they
think that it's
like writing music is so [ __ ] hard
because when i
i have a couple friends who are really
famous producers they let me sit in
these writing rooms
and i'm watching what these people do
it's [ __ ] hard it's hard
it's and everybody's like fighting for
points yeah he's like hey
i wrote that part i did this and like i
want points for that it's like yo this
is a very
cutthroat industry here yeah and it is
a very cut throat industry but um i've
been very fortunate to be in
in rooms where i think my back track to
my experience in nashville and all that
stuff as a teenager i think
i also learned a lot of tactics of like
finding the right people that
who who are compatible with my
creativity yeah
so i'm very strategic of who i work with
and
um especially for producers and other
songwriters or
um yeah just creative
i think because of that experience it
gave me a little bit of like a
know-how like also kind of like a tactic
of
when i go to a room with like three two
other people so it's like a three-way
there's like kind of like an implied
you know agreement that it's split three
ways even so
there's no fighting for points there's
no like
i wrote you know what i mean like i
wrote this line and that line and that
line i think
if you have that community uh kind of
mentality to it
it makes it so much easier and when
people are more at ease they become more
creative and just more open
yeah which makes the session better so
um that's kind of
one thing that i do too with with
co-writes or collaborations but it is
overall a very cutthroat industry i'm
not gonna
how did it feel for you when you went
from being the published writer to going
into youtube and kind of having your
face and your name attached to this
music too
because that's such a different vibe
from just you know having your product
taken by somebody else
versus people get to attach the music to
your face and your likeness
i mean i was you know first of all i
grew up in texas
in a not very diverse community yeah so
i've always been like this
token asian friend token you know what i
mean so uh
and then when youtube started to happen
obviously
it was the asian american community that
gathered and like
like embraced me and to a point that
when i started doing all these live
events for
asian american communities and colleges
and universities
i kind of had a culture shock yeah yeah
it was just like wow like
these kids actually know my songs word
for word and like
uh i think one of the first shows that i
did um
was in inland empire
and i posted my song meant to be and
that was like one of the first songs i
posted on youtube
and then that very show people were like
singing along and that freaked me out
how crazy yeah
isn't that insane very insane and i just
like to this
to this day and i i think back about
those memories and i'm just like oh
that's
that was a great memory because i know
things get really hard in the industry
it's not always
uphill it's always just up and down and
sometimes those memories kind of like
propel me to
the next thing and to be inspired to do
more writing i guess
isn't that crazy though like how you can
create something that's probably more
simple to you but it becomes like a more
complex thing to everybody else
like your your music too it's like i
still listen to that song
till this [ __ ] day and when it pops
up i remember where i was when i first
listened to it
so it's like i mean i was super young i
was just getting over like a breakup or
some [ __ ]
you know so like these are the musics
that become like very attached to our
emotions
yeah and you know what i feel like when
a singer songwriter does that like a
piece of you
ends up being a part of everybody else's
story it's like i'm part of
their your soundtrack you know and and
it's funny because sometimes you know i
would
meet random fans wherever i go and um
they would literally tell me like a life
story like
background of like how they met their
yeah
wife or husband and they use this song
for
proposal they use and it's it's so cool
because it's like
as a loner you know introverted person
it's like
i feel like i have a lot of friends that
i didn't know existed
yeah yeah yeah when did you start
writing music for the first time
probably 15 16 oh wow and i got the
the i mean i've always been musical i
sang a lot since i was a kid
ever since i can remember typical
filipino thing
piano lessons violin lessons and um and
then guitar was a
something that piqued my interest
because everybody in my
you know my friend's circle started
playing guitar and um
yeah so 16 15 and then i got my deal
around like
18. that's crazy yeah and then that that
occurred about three
i would say four years because you know
they don't sign you right away they kind
of like
do a test run with you then they sign
you um and then so by the time
21 22 that's when kind of
youtube life happened so 10 years and
or so in that's that's where i am right
now that's the same
when you write music too like how
what's your process like right because
you know trying to do that was has
always been hard right
especially like like i always say to
first first easier second verse the
worst
yeah well anything goes i don't try to
con you know confine myself but i'm very
melodically inclined
i think melodies just come very easy
and then i think because of my
background with you know my training
with songwriting i think
i became a better lyricist but i don't
think i was born a lyricist
so i usually start melody
chords then lyrics and then i will weave
in lyrics as i go if i have like a spark
within while i do my lalalas and the the
blurbs and all that stuff for men to be
what was your inspiration for that song
so that was not a personal song i
actually it's
it was kind of like a songwriting
exercise from crazy
for myself to for a friend's wedding oh
wow
yeah as instead of because they wanted
me to sing for the wedding anyway right
and they i think they asked
they originally asked me to sing um at
last at james
okay which i've always sung on a lot of
friends part weddings and stuff
but i was like why don't i just write a
song and hopefully they like it
and and also just kind of had the idea
of putting it on a cd and like
give that as their wedding gift you know
um
how lucky how [ __ ] lucky of you
this was a long time ago and i didn't
think much of it i just thought like
well it's
this is gonna be fun so i gave that gift
that cd like
like a week before their wedding or
something and then
the bride listened to it and it's like
you know what i'm gonna
play this i want you to sing this when i
walk down the aisle
and so i'm like what like it's like a
new like
a revision in the program because she
loved it so much and so that's what i
did
slowly stars go out each night
dark needs a light kiss the sun good
night
[Music]
new day comes as
and every time you hold my hand
[Music]
there's an understanding of who i
am new life is born
unlike before
i'm now
you can feel it in the summer breeze
tonight the world's at ease
you are the one for me
after all the waiting i
can't finally breathe
earth and say what they make
i will love you all through
how my days happiness
happens when our hearts combine
when it's you i'm with i come
alive it's just so good
see
doll and
[Applause]
to be
your love is like amazing grace
sounds so sweet i could almost taste
i've been given more than what i could
ever
ask for right
[Music]
[Music]
that is
you are the one for me
after all the waiting i
can finally
earth and sky say what they make
how we'll love you all through
how my days happiness
happens when our hearts combine
when it's you i'm with i cover my life
it's just so good see
[Music]
i feel at home whenever
you're around i feel so
sick you're so safe and sound what else
can i say
[Music]
what else can i say
you are the one for me
after all the waiting i
can't finally breathe
say what they may i
will love you all through how
my days happiness
happens when our hearts combine
when it's you i'm with our common life
it's just so good
[Music]
we
[Music]
we are meant
to be
this podcast is brought to you by
ipvanish if you are out there and you
don't have
a vpn a virtual private network by
ipvanish
you my friends are missing out because
people are stooping on your data
you need a vpn and you need ipvanish my
friends
just like i have it doesn't matter what
you're doing whether you're having a
good old time on the internet or not
nobody should be in your business nobody
should be collecting your data well
guess what
because you don't have ipvanish that's
what's happening to you right now
here's everything you get with ipvanish
anonymous ip address this means your
personal ip address can't be tracked by
anyone on the web
circumvent any online censorship get
protection when using public wi-fi
super important so go to ipvanish.com
brain claim your 65
savings they have plans starting at just
349 or 31.49
a year this is the time to sign up with
our discount and the current promotional
offerings you can get a vpn for 65
off their usual offerings ipvanish is
the best of the best even rated 4.7 out
of 5 on trustpilot and that's with more
than 6 000 reviews
so show these guys some love they are
repeat
sponsors remember it's ipvanish.com
brain to get the deal and start
protecting yourself online
and then um that was the intention of
the song and it wasn't until i had
that i put it on youtube that it became
bigger because otherwise if i didn't put
it on youtube that was just going to be
there like yeah yeah yeah
and there was no like marketing push or
putting it out there it was just you
know that's how that's how
youtube used to be though and we were
talking about this earlier today like
the
kind of like how youtube started back in
the day there was no
objective it was just we create just
because we want to create
and what that allowed for the space to
have was a lot of different content
whether it was good or bad it didn't
matter
to me at the time it was like at least
we have different choices
well now everybody's content is
relatively the same
it's just a different iteration of it
you know and so i think that's the hard
part cause when people ask like who do
you watch on youtube it's like i watch
people fix cars
i watch people i watch like diy channels
yeah this is what i watch i stop
watching personal content because a lot
of people stop
being really personal with their stuff
yeah very formulaic
when i when i watched like content back
in the day like i remember when i first
watched somebody like ryan higa right
he wasn't my cup of tea and people were
like well how come you don't find them
funny it's like because it's not what i
laugh at
i never said i didn't appreciate his
stuff though i it was different
it's just not the [ __ ] that i grew up
laughing and i grew up in [ __ ] stupid
hood [ __ ]
so when i saw his stuff i was like oh
this shit's like corny childish [ __ ]
yeah you know but people say oh so you
don't like his stuff i never said that
i like his stuff yeah i just don't
personally find it funny but i like what
he does because it was so creative and
so [ __ ] different it's very hard to
find that nowadays when somebody shows
me their channel it's like i already
know what you're gonna do i know what
you're gonna say i know the jokes that
you're gonna do
yeah it's it's it's kind of sad to be
honest it makes me sad i don't even go
on youtube as much anymore unless if i
really
like for example like i need to
troubleshoot something in the computer
it's very purposeful now you know i'm
like okay like
i'm sorry i started redoing my yard at
the back area and i've been doing it for
like the past week
and i've been going on youtube watching
other girls do their stuff yeah i'm like
yo what is this what's boho chic what is
this i'm learning all this new
terminology right
damn that's just tight and i'm watching
their videos over and over again yeah
it's very purposeful like but before i
used to watch it for entertainment
yeah i remember personally when i got
introduced to the whole youtube
asian american community you know it's
like whoever posts
a video i would just go watch it just
for like oh i want to know what he's
doing i want to know
what she's up to it's like it's almost
like
your friends um posting something
and then you just want you're curious
what they're up to and
yeah i i miss those days yeah and i mean
you're
like i said the biggest difference was
from you like i think when i heard
other youtube musicians i stopped
listening to a lot of their stuff
because
i already knew they were going to do a
cover oh the number one hit of them
exactly because they're trying to get
this algorithm yeah and they would do
nothing with the song so it would just
be
it's like i would just listen to the
original artist
yeah i didn't want that and i felt like
you know there were a few people within
you know the musician community who have
who has told me at that time it's like
mostly you should do more covers so you
should be
you can get more subscribers and bigger
and i'm just like nah
you know that was kind of the sacrifice
i made you know because people always
say why aren't you
you know you should be like bigger or
you should be like more popular and all
that stuff
i think it's just because i'm not driven
by that in a way
is to my detriment i think but um
when it comes to the youtube hustle or
like that stuff
but it's you know but at the same time
now years later
i can look back and say i stay true to
myself you know it's like that's
who i am i have no problems with covers
like covers are
[ __ ] great you know i just what are
you gonna do with it is the question you
know
and i think that's the part where it was
just like i always give [ __ ] to my buddy
jason jason chen right okay
the [ __ ] the the cover masturbator is
what i call them this guy
like i've never seen somebody do so many
[ __ ] covers this guy's never missed a
cover
a day in his life like [ __ ] it's
literally covers never sleep that's just
that's his [ __ ] dude but it's
consistency though i respect it i
totally respect the game
and he came on the podcast and he was
talking about how like yeah like it
stopped being so much fun for me now
it's just like
it's a program now i just do it all the
time yeah i could tell like you sing
with
literally zero [ __ ] soul like it's
just you're robotic with your [ __ ]
and you know at times too it's like why
do it
but you know for him it's just he's been
doing it for so long this is his routine
and that's where it starts to make me a
little sad too it's like well you have
an ability to be a great musician
whether you choose to do it or not yeah
but why do something that you dread
like i can't live like that yeah and and
the thing is
i think psychologically music has always
been my haven
right or my way of coping with the world
and dealing with the world that
for me to turn it into something that is
stale and repetitive yeah i i don't know
i think
deep down i knew i couldn't do it yeah
yeah so whatever i put out there whether
it be
on spotify or itunes or whatever it's
because i wanted to do it
yeah it's because i was convicted to i
know it's kind of an idealistic point of
view
and way to do things and it's not
necessarily the most
efficient or i don't know like yeah i
mean
but that's the difference though right
like there's
objective and purpose is very different
right so if your objective is to get as
many eyes on you as possible
yeah yeah do the top one hit covers
whatever yeah that's going to happen and
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
but if your objective in life isn't for
fame and notoriety
then what's the point yeah you're still
getting nothing out of it
right because it's really where you
place value in things right so
we talk about this all the time where
i'm like yeah i could have done pranks
pranks are the easiest [ __ ] ever
yeah like it's at the sacrifice of
somebody else's comfort
and i can do that all [ __ ] day yeah
but when i look back at my life
and like oh you're the guy who did
pranks cool let me go [ __ ] kill
myself now
you know i can't live like that yeah i
just can't live like that
like people place va people like to
place their personal values on to you
and they don't ask you what do you value
what do you care about
and they measure you there's your
success based on what they find valuable
it's like well that's
your measurement of success yeah like
you can't put that on me
yeah you know exactly so um i think
deep down i knew that or i i and i
internalized that without really
being um you know sometimes i'm not very
articulate when it comes to that stuff
but like
yeah so i i was just driven by just
creating there's just a high
when i make new songs or like this past
this last week actually you know i was
in the studio like three days straight
create like wrote one song second song
and then third song i
did all the vocals like that stuff to me
is very exhilarating dude
[ __ ] three how the [ __ ] do you do
that how is it possible
it's it's fun you know you know jesse
barrera i don't know if you know
jesse is [ __ ] amazing too by the way
he's an amazing musician
you know i would say consistently one of
my main partner in crimes when it right
when it comes to production and
writing songs yeah so we just decided
like you know it's been like a year and
a half since i've been back and i was
just like
uh let's write a song i don't have
anything in my head right now but let's
just show up
so i just that's what we agreed on and
we wrote
it's like yes you know riding a bike and
it's fun
and it reminded me because you know this
past year has been pretty tough for me
personally like a lot of people but
um you know it reminded me that like
this is really what i
you know want to do and it's good though
like i i always enjoy that because
you know i talk about um there's a lot
on this podcast where i talk about
you know why i just said it before
purpose and foundation like if you
always go back to what kind of makes you
tick
you don't ever feel like you're losing
anything yeah right because you
love music like for a lot of people
music becomes their savior
right it's a way of expression and like
you said for yourself when you started
off you're a very reserved
quiet person and so a way of your
expression is your music
and there's probably no other way you
would have been able to express yourself
outside of music
pretty much right because it wasn't
because
if you're somebody who's a little more
reserved
how do you do it you do it in the art
form that you really connect with yeah
and that was music for you
totally so it's kind of crazy though
like with the same effect that you had
for yourself you gave it to other people
too
yeah and it's a great it's a good
feeling too it's
it's it makes me feel like i'm doing
something good
in this crazy friggin world like it's
very overwhelming like even just
reading the news and stuff and watching
the news but how was that pandemic for
you
um to be honest in the first the first
uh couple months
it wasn't that bad yeah i don't mind
being alone and
being nice i mean obviously i was kind
of you know i was sad that i couldn't do
shows i couldn't
travel and all that stuff that i would
usually do
pre-pandemic but then like i just
hunkered down and like
you know planned like online things a
lot more and
and i did obviously online events for
for
colleges and stuff like that that kind
of sustained me and the only
collaborations that i did during the
pandemic
was with jeremy passion and gay bondok
so the three of us wrote a few songs
within 2020. um um which by the way
you're invited to the show
yes i'll be there you was crazy i saw
you i remember i messaged you or i
tagged you guys like what the [ __ ] what
did this happen
like there was literally a collab album
you guys did i didn't [ __ ]
know about it yeah oh my god my word
what's going on here yeah it was kind of
a like an organically
formed idea it was at the beginning it
was just me and jeremy did a show
together and it
went well and then all of a sudden like
why don't we add gabe into the mix and
gabe
agreed like a year later to do three of
us do a show
all went well so we did a lot more shows
after that so it became kind of like a
touring kind of lineup
and then all of a sudden we just said
why don't we go to
the studio and just do like a trio thing
and
yeah it's it's been really like a cool
combo of talent because you know we're
all in the soulful realm
yeah but like you know jeremy's more 90s
r b and i'm joined music soul child
yes yeah and then like gabe's a little
bit more of the the
john mayerish kind of guys
and i'm more of the folky kind of like
you know singer-songwriter but with a
splashy soul in there so it's like the
three of us kind of bring
you know like different palettes of soul
and then we just put it all together
your guys you guys had a it's
interesting with the influence that all
three
you have like on a lot of like young
people growing up specifically asian
american kids when it came to music
right
because when it came to a perception of
what like asian americans can do
specifically in this realm of music
there wasn't a lot of representation
yeah well because they we weren't taken
seriously exactly you know
like either karaoke singers or they
never knew that you know asian people
can sing
and so i remember even in high school um
jeremy started blowing up yeah and it
was like these little it was
lemonade like lemonade blew up and then
next to him was gabe and there was like
this who's better do you like gay better
do you like jeremy better
like people would always argue that back
and forth and they're different they're
so different
so different genre is different it's
like you can't even compare it's like
apples and oranges yeah like i like
apples i like orange juice yeah they're
both very [ __ ] different yeah yeah
we're a fruit salad yeah everybody was
so
unique but that that song lemonade blew
the [ __ ] up i mean it's still going
strong
till this day people still know that
song yeah that song
helped me lose my virginity
you want to talk about [ __ ] using
music like i use that song to get [ __ ]
all the time jeremy thank you so much i
i lost my v card because of you it was
the worst sex she ever had
100 i had no idea what i was doing oh my
gosh yeah
but that's when i started picking up a
guitar
because i heard music like that i mean
there was christian music i was i was a
church boy you know
so i played simple chords but i was like
what are these chords they sound so
different
yeah it's not your classic [ __ ] g a b
c you know there's like it's like the
major sevens yeah all these diminished
i'm like what is this
noise it sounds so good yeah and he was
the first introduction to that show i
love that that's awesome
you know and i was like oh this this
this is way different from what i was
normally taught
yeah and then it just started expanding
everybody's musical palette
they didn't know this stuff and i just
remember hearing him and i love music
soul child i was like
he definitely listens to a lot of music
soul child yeah
it's funny our friendship sparked back
in my space
oh really yeah dude he he actually
reached out to me
uh to because he was currently in a long
distance relationship
at that point and he wrote like a half
of a song and he was like
um i would i think he already had the
idea to make it a duet but it wasn't
finished
so he apparently he was already a fan of
my music and he reached out to me and
said like
if if you're down to finish the song
with me you know he's very reserved
too another shy guy and i said yeah sure
and we it ended up to be paper airplane
i don't know if you know that song yes
yeah so that song became like the first
introduction
of for the both of us as collaborators
and friends
what's hilarious is that he didn't think
i was filipino and i didn't think he was
filipino
who's this cambodian man i thought he
was like
black half japanese or something like
that and then he thought i was puerto
rican
that's [ __ ] funny dude you guys are
just racially ambiguous as [ __ ] you
don't know what the [ __ ] you are
so he literally asked me when i actually
flew to san francisco where he was
so i could record the song with him and
he was like
you're not are you filipino i was like
yeah what did you think i was
you're like [ __ ] but what are you
talking about
i was like i thought you were like
puerto rican or something i'm like
whoa okay because the reasoning behind
his thing is that he said he doesn't i
don't sound like
a filipino okay the way i approach
singing is not typical of a filipino
female artist you didn't do a whitney
houston cover that's why
that's why you don't do covers you
[ __ ] make original music
it's the most unfilipino thing about you
i'll dare you that's hilarious yeah
so and um also another un filipino thing
about me is that i'm kind of
anti-karaoke oh my god hilarious
i honestly feel a lot of musicians are
anti-karaoke though
okay because there's a lot of
expectation when you do karaoke yeah
so it's like what's competitive yeah
it's like you know i'm gonna sing every
song i can't sing though like
that's the point of karaoke i'm going to
do bruno mars and i'm going to try
singing in his key
and i'm going to be hockey for a solid
three minutes be prepared
you know i just remember being a kid
right look because
you know family gatherings they they
every household has like a magic mic or
like a thing
and so a magic mic if you guys don't
know what it is it's literally a whole
karaoke machine
and a microphone it's like that's what a
magic mic is pretty much
whenever they pull it out like you know
for a birthday party or graduation party
whatever
i slowly make my way out and just
incognito like just sneak out and the
pressures yeah like my sister loves it
my dad loves it like they enjoy that
stuff i just like kind of like
no there's always like some random uncle
at a family party that just waits that's
his debut he's like
waiting yeah has the song queued up and
everything exactly
i'm like [ __ ] this guy sings the
same three songs every [ __ ] time
and he acts as if we don't know that he
prepped this already yeah
you prep this it's usually like an elvis
song
or some some frank sinatra song or
something
i used to always have a friend like i'm
not gonna say his name but his uncle
like
he's kind of sensitive but he would
always like he would always sing the
same
three [ __ ] songs and when it was like
some all these music i still don't
remember what the songs were to this day
but they would ask like oh are you gonna
sing guys i don't know i'm going to sing
today
like of course you know dude of course
you do
and he goes i don't know and he goes let
me see
three songs i'm like how do you know the
numbers to the song already then dude
like you're gonna do it and if nobody
asks him he gets a little butt hurting
[ __ ]
yeah i'm like because he knows he wants
to impress everybody and he wants
everybody
well you know give them some shine i
know but it's like it's kind of [ __ ]
it was so [ __ ] annoying we're like
here your uncle goes again he goes i
know because especially because he was
so bad
yeah he's so bad that's so funny
yeah i mean like songwriting to me is
just like another kind of like
i don't know just another level
creativity that i tapped into that was
just like i'm hooked
you know once i started kind of doing it
like regularly
that after a while like if i don't write
songs i get a little antsy i get really
anxious
that's amazing that's weird though but
that's great though that means that's
what
that's what you're destined to do if it
if you're itchy because you haven't done
it in a while
that's what people search for for their
whole [ __ ] life is purpose people
look for that and they don't know what
that feels like they
every day they wake up and they're
trying to find that feeling where you
when you have something in your life
that you know that you can't live
without a lot of these kids when they
ask
they want to know what that feels like
they don't know yeah
there's so many options that they just
they question everything and they don't
try to do things
and you know it's interesting that you
say that because i think in
i guess mid-20s when i was already in
the thick of like the youtube thing it's
still kind of like an uncharted
territory right like yeah i was popular
on youtube and i have this following but
it's still like
you know a new thing to navigate there's
no like formula like you should do this
you should do that like i think
everybody on youtube whether you you be
a comedian or a musician like
at that point in around circa 2008
it's like everybody's just kind of
making it up as they go yeah you know
um you know i went back home to my
hometown and like
my high school friends or like childhood
friends are like all fascinated by what
i do
and i was so insecure that was like
you guys have like the nine to five
stable jobs and i
envy you guys and i'm over here like
just being anxious about like what to do
next and what to
you know i have to formulate everything
i don't have a manager i don't have to
i don't know what to expect by next
month or next year i don't know how long
this will last
and so but in a way it's like
i think back it's like 10 years later
i'm still in it you know it's kind of
weird to to think that it's like because
i've found something um i guess my
purpose
and and my calling i guess is i'm still
here and then a lot of
my friends are just like changing jobs
and
i don't know a little lost there's like
a there's like a struggle in that though
yeah you know
like yeah you know your purpose but look
at all the stuff that you had to go
through you had to go through the whole
nashville experience
and even after going through all that
[ __ ] you're still doing what you like
yeah and that's that's the important
part right and i always say that about
people who want to go into entertainment
it's like do you really want this
or do you like the glitz and the glamour
well you don't know about all the [ __ ]
that you have to deal with
every [ __ ] day to be in this position
it's hard you are scrutinized for
everything
everything especially like as a female
musician dude like not only are you
scrutinized for your music which is the
last on the list
it's about how you look you know like
that's the biggest thing
yeah i mean i've dealt with like you
know
body you know issues like i i was very
insecure about how i look
even just because i grew up in a
community where like
you know being asian isn't really looked
at as beautiful necessarily you know and
i had to find that inner like
like self-love in a way especially when
i
started like seeing younger kids who
look like me
who look up to me and listen to my music
it's like if they look up to me and like
listen
and are inspired by what my work then i
have to
kind of walk the walk and talk to talk
and like feel good about
who i am you know and i had it's almost
like i had to backtrack with my healing
was it was it hard for you growing up
because you were like you were the main
asian person in that area
is or is that it wasn't i mean i'm not
like saying that i was you know
bullied or whatever it's just like
you're always going to be different
you know people were nice to me and
people were um
you know i guess they like what i do and
stuff but there's always that feeling of
you're not them or like i wasn't invited
to
everything or you know you're always
kind of the
extra yeah friend yeah optional friend
that
like oh okay do we invite melissa or no
yeah i don't know
so i've always been um just
i think i had to be okay with myself you
know and so like songwriting is a loner
activity
i don't need anybody to write truth so
i mean you also talked about like you
mentioned like you had body image issues
and stuff yeah which i feel
i've had that conversation with a lot of
like female artist friends right oh yeah
it's very common where they feel like
you know
everybody has an opinion about how they
look first before their art
right which is very [ __ ] true yeah
especially in this space more so than
how guys get it
like that's just the fact because like
for me i've been fat my whole life
but nobody gave really a [ __ ] about it
because i was a comedian dude i was a
funny guy
so it was okay but then you kind of
put that on the other shoe of a woman
and she's like a bigger girl that just
becomes who they are and a part of their
identity
yeah and it's just you know and it's
also too cultural
you know in my family it's like every
filipino whether you're
you're bigger or not they always kind of
body shape you know yeah even though
they feed you everything that's brown
and not a single vegetable
and then like and then like when you
don't eat and you lose weight it's like
oh you're not eating enough go eat yeah
it's like what do you want from me
what i was like it's like why didn't you
gain so much weight
i don't know everything is pork
everything is pork and rice
do we have a [ __ ] vegetable in this
white rice not even brown
rice it's like the only thing that's not
brown is the rice it's like
it's like we have vegetables in the pan
sit like that's in there it's brown now
though
so there's not a vegetable anymore what
the [ __ ] are you talking about yeah
so um you know who has helped me with
dealing issues with like being female
in the music industry
[Music]
love don't fight it
given to love and love don't deny it
together the walls will come crashing
down
to the ground and finally see
the stars
there'll be more
[Music]
but together we'll spark the light in
our
eyes and take flight and finally see
the stars
[Music]
and the longings
of our hearts
will subside and
rescue us from
heart when we're
almost drowning
in that even say that we're done
love don't fight it
given to love and loved all day night
together the walls will come crashing
down
to the ground finally see
the stars
there'll be more
blanket at night waters and suns
but together we'll spark the light in
our
eyes and take flight and finally
see the stars
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
when we're almost
drowning in the deep
and say that we die
[Music]
together the walls will come crashing
down
to the ground finally see
the stars
there'll be more moments the blanket
at night us in silence
but together we'll spark the light in
our
eyes and say flying
finally see the stars
together the wars will come crashing
down to the ground and finally
see
the stars
[Music]
this podcast is brought to you by liquid
death my friends what is liquid death it
sounds a lot more intense than it
actually is
it's actually delicious spring
water now i bet you're wondering why
would i buy a
can that looks like beer but when it's
just water well that's the thing guys
what you don't know is that a majority
of recycled plastic
recycling plants don't want to recycle
them because they actually don't make a
lot of money from them but aluminum
cans yes they are a hundred percent
recyclable and super profitable for
those companies so they
always recycle them so you're actually
saving the earth liquid death is
death to plastics which is why i love
this
company do you hate the [ __ ] earth
how dare you drink water out a [ __ ]
water bottle drink it out of a liquid
death can
i love it i actually even got pulled
over once by a cop because i thought i
was drinking beer as i was driving
and i explained to them spring water and
well
wasn't their face red you freaking
idiots dude liquid death is the best you
have to try this out
and by the way um if you're not drinking
water what are you doing and if you are
going to do it you might as well do it
like this because liquid death is the
[ __ ] so remember my friends go to
liquiddeth.com
brain to get a free set of koozies with
your first order of any case of water or
just grab
some at any whole foods or 7 11.
my favorite favorite drink of water cop
yourself some liquid death
is a india re so i don't know if you
know her
i love india oh yeah so she's like i
that's kind of like a cool story right
there um so when i was back in nashville
um they you know my
the team that i was with or was assigned
to me like what do we do with melissa
what kind of producers what kind of
sound
and then they finally found like an idea
which was kind of cool is like
acoustic soul record which india's first
major album was all produced and
written in nashville oh yeah she's from
atlanta right and then they recorded
everything
you know in nashville um and then a lot
of her producers for that record
were all based in nashville so they were
like putting all the i guess
i guess the building blocks of like oh
that's right with this and that and that
because of indiari because india was you
know she was
kind of the pioneering sound of r b
sounds with acoustic instrumentation
and since i was doing that and i had the
soulful sound they were like oh why
don't we
kind of model melissa's artistry that
way
but then before all that stuff happened
i worked with one producer
that she worked with his name was blue
miller
um but after that everything fell
through right
years later i started working here in
nash in los angeles
i got to write with and record with
david ryan harris
i don't know you know oh [ __ ] yeah how
[ __ ] crazy
yeah that was that was another story i
just messaged him on tumblr
and he said sure let's work together and
i went
to his studio and this out he's like one
of my favorite people and and
what the [ __ ] hold on a second you're
just like hey and he goes okay
well basically remember tumblr you know
those q and a's
so i think so ask me anything so i i
kind of like just message like a fan
girl and say like i'm a fan it's not a
question i would love to
work or sing with you one of these days
and i didn't put it as anonymous because
i want him to like click on the link to
check out my music and i think
he checked out my youtube or something
and that's all it took that's all it
took and so like [ __ ] nuts is that
that was kind of like a miracle but
anyways it led to me working with him
i got to know his family like i would
occasionally in the past have visited
his house just to kind of have dinner
with them it's
like a cool relationship that i have
like even the first show back in hotel
cafe a couple weeks ago
since pandemic he was the first show and
he called me up on stage
just on a whim and i had to just go
like my my anxiety levels were just up
the roof but i went up and saying
something
i don't know what i did but all this to
say drh or david ryan harris is like one
of my
favorite people and he was working with
india re
wow and one and you know years ago he
just called me in
and like i was in texas at that time he
was like well i just wanted to let you
know that
i'm working with indiari here in atlanta
writing songs with her
and we just spent like a good hour
watching your youtube videos
i'm like that's great so ever since
then like india has kind of like been
oh when i met when i finally met her in
la
you know i was starstruck when she was
in the same room
and again being a reserved chick i
didn't want to introduce myself she went
across the room and actually said are
you melissa
and i said yes i'm india here's my
number
that's what she she did i swear so ever
since then she and i would like text
we wrote a song together eventually i
opened for her
um tour back in 2019
she's been like a big sis holy [ __ ] that
was like two years ago
yeah yeah so it was before the pandemic
right before the pandemic and
you know it's been kind of and i just
released a song with her
and um yeah it i feel like those moments
and those
that kind of like stories that i can
tell it's just kind of makes
could you imagine though i mean all in a
youtube little
it's crazy isn't it crazy how it works
out like that too yeah also it's like
your personal choices that led to this
point
because imagine and just imagine right
the videos that she saw were just you
just doing covers every week
do you think you would have had that
conversation with her i don't know 100
you wouldn't have
i guarantee you you wouldn't have had
that conversation yeah even with like
like david ryan harris he saw the music
that you create your original music
yeah people see covers a million times
over but it's very seldom that you see
people create original music that they
wrote themselves
from from melody to lyrics that they put
out
even now when people say like singer
songwriter or whatever right
a lot of them don't like people don't
know that about the industry like when
sometimes like people like beyonce she
has a writing credit for it
she do [ __ ] she probably changed the
line exactly
but they're like oh she's a singer she
didn't write that song yeah like
that these are just f i'm like i love
beyonce i mean i thought oh my god a fly
landed here and i just caught in my hand
oh my goodness i'm a ninja hold on
let me throw this fly away i literally
just caught a [ __ ] fly in the palm of
my hand
that's [ __ ] oh i'm mr miyagi i don't
know what the [ __ ]
how [ __ ] that that's
that's hilarious
history he caught a fly
like mr miyagi with the [ __ ] palm of
my head it's on a [ __ ] video
it really happened you should have just
put your hand up in the camera to
just like my word i just i'm amazed at
myself right now
i'm super yeah but we're talking about
like you know artists who write their
own music
yeah and they get a lot of credit for it
but they don't write their own music
it's not to take away from the artists
they're great performers they sing well
but it takes a very special person to
write takes a lot of
a special person or like a really
traumatized person
in their lives what about with like uh
the song that i connected with try like
how did you write that song
i think i was inspired by a dude that
like
i know i wasn't supposed to be with but
i was just very drawn to that guy
and i think that was kind of like the
the
it's not really autobiographical the
whole way through
but that was the jumping point of that
song
and again it's just kind of sometimes a
lot of my songs are a mix of
of real life events but i mix it with
just other kind of scenarios in there
yeah that's definitely one there's a
song called brave face i don't know if
you know that one
but that's autobiographical like yes
there's some that are very like
literally what i'm going through or what
i went through
but some are you know again as a
songwriter you have skills to kind of
like okay i'm gonna pull this from this
story i'm gonna pull this from
my life and sometimes it's just a
hodgepodge like a quilt
that you kind of woven together into a
scene
what was that brave face about uh well
brayface is just talking about like
seeing a guy that used to date and then
you're with somebody else
oh [ __ ] that sucks yeah that's like one
of those terrible feelings
the lyric goes i put on a brave face
every time i see you and you're with her
you know that's all yeah it's just it's
a simple song
gabe bonduck absolutely loves that song
and he you know whenever we do tours and
it's like
sing that song sing that's like i don't
want to sing that song i don't want to
be all like
self-pity song you know like
that's what music does like i mean it's
it's also like a generational thing the
way like music is shifting now right
because it's very i mean some people can
call it overproduced that's how i feel
sometimes
this music is made to be a hit but none
of the music lasts
right yeah it's like a machine
especially now with spotify
there's like billions and millions of
songs pushed out every week
that's why i like you so i just had
jennifer chung on right like oh jennifer
i love her
jennifer is a great songwriter i love
her people don't know that about her
yeah right so they're like oh the song
is original i was like no jennifer wrote
that song
yeah you know and my fiance for heard
one of jennifer's songs recently she
didn't know that jennifer wrote her own
music
and i played it for her and then she
started tearing up i was like this is
that's that's an age of songwriting
that's starting to disappear
storytelling oh right i think it's
always going to come back though
yeah i feel like in the uk they still
have that yeah
they really appreciate r b they really
appreciate songwriting um
i think it's just right now it's about
like pop hits that you kind of remember
listen to for a second and it disappears
yeah and that's why a lot of the music
that i listen to now
it's if it's from i mean i
don't know maybe i'm just an old head i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is but the
the storytelling aspect of music is a
part that i miss because it always gets
me to go back to that song and listen to
it again
yeah and you know what i also think
about the phenomenon in this in this day
and age is that
people whether especially young people
they're not
given the space and time to have a
relationship with the music
yes you know what i'm saying because i
remember i think the reason why all
these
you know a generation of asian american
kids like still listen to lemonade or
still listen to meant to be and like
gentlemen don't or whatever
it's just because it puts them in
you know a relationship with a certain
time of their lives whether it be like
an old girlfriend or like just a good
time a simpler time
i i don't know if that happens now
because everything is churning up
so quickly from tick tock trends to like
everything is just so fast it's on to
the next one oh the next one on to the
next one it's like
that's why i feel like i don't know i
maybe i'm just getting older too it's
like i'm just
it's just a societal change now too and
i like i remember i mentioned this too
like jay-z was talking about this and
that's what i remember
back in the day when you had to review a
song or an album right they were given
to very specific critics
so before if you wanted to be a music
critic you couldn't just put up a
[ __ ] blog and just start talking out
of your ass yeah
just because you listen to me it doesn't
mean that you're a curator of art or
that you understand music at all
yeah so a lot of these people who would
do music or album reviews
they were given the album a month ahead
of time yeah then they listened to the
[ __ ] album
from song to song beginning to end yeah
and then they placed their judgment on
it yeah well now
some song an album will drop on spotify
and people say greatest album of all
time
you didn't even have enough time to
listen to it yeah how can you say that
you probably got paid
you know so when people say this they're
like oh this is the best thing i've ever
heard how you've only had it for a day
yeah like that's impossible for you to
understand what they it's like me when i
when i first heard um
uh john legend revolver okay i hated
that album at first
i didn't even like it i didn't like the
[ __ ] and then i remember i was like
wait hold on let me just give it a
chance give it a chance and i didn't
listen to the song from beginning to end
i went skip skip skip skip skip skip
skip and i was like hold on let me just
listen to it in the car ride because i
was going from
sacramento to l.a okay and i was like
let me just listen to it and i'm like
this is my favorite john legend album
oh yeah it's like you're creating a
relationship with somebody's work
right so it's like people don't do that
anymore it's just
it's sad in a way it's sad like the
amount of effort it takes to become a
songwriter and create this stuff people
people just want to digest and [ __ ] it
out and then go on to the next yeah
and i i think for somebody like me i'm
fortunate enough to have
a generation of people who still want to
have a relationship with
i guess the work that i do or i've done
in the past so it's like
it's kind of cool i'm in that generation
of like
you know the the asian american folks
that still are very nostalgic
yeah but i mean you're always creating
things
all the [ __ ] time have you have you i
always wondered too with somebody like
you and i
and i've always thought about this for
other like youtubers like
do other youtubers ever hit you up to
write music for them
uh no like i wonder why not though
it's like i would have be would have
been open to it but that would be great
because like i i see some other people
as like you you have the talent but you
can't write music you know you know
there's people who write music
i mean i would love to do it but i don't
know if there's like a some sort of like
they don't think about it or i don't
know i don't know they should have been
a cool
thing i always wondered too because it's
just like it's like a genre that people
haven't really
liked maybe they feel like they can do
it too yeah and then you
i listen to their music like you can't
do it yet yet because it's not
you haven't that's a muscle that's
that's something you have to practice
yeah yeah
and some people just don't they don't
hear it you know we know when we hear
good music but we don't know how to get
to that point
yeah i mean other musicians and
songwriters singer songwriters have
reached out to me to write
but not necessarily youtube musicians
and i don't know
if maybe it's because i haven't been
very present with youtube
you know i don't know if that's the case
but you know i think they just need to
know
my music outside of music of youtube to
actually know my stuff because i don't
know if youtube is really representative
of what i do now completely
do i think one of the things that i get
really sad about um
when it comes to music too is that
people tend to uh
they don't move past the emulation phase
of an artist that they like
right yeah so it's like like they wait
the way they sing is exactly the way
that yeah
it's like yeah we all have influences
right
but when are you going to find your own
voice yeah and they stop
they don't they don't really have that
and so i always see it typically
when it comes to people who want to you
can see it in their live music it's like
guess what you don't have melodyne in
autotune anymore you're going to perform
this
live and you chose to do a very
difficult song yeah so
just to let you know you're going to
suck because it's hard
it's performing live is a completely
different knowledge i love it though
well let's just be real like your tone
your your vocal tone is really [ __ ]
good and you have really good control
thank you a lot of people don't have
that though it's hard it is [ __ ]
hard it's hard but it is a muscle though
it's just kind of like working out i
guess it's just
you know um i i have to practice now
because it's been a year and
and and some changed since i really did
like a
full-on set yeah um
so this com upcoming shows i'm gonna
have to really prepare myself
i mean it's it's crazy though when i see
like that that idea of
i once again i see it a lot in people
who try to go out and sing and they sing
outside of their range just because they
heard another artist sing in that range
it's like
the range is the least important it's
like how do you sound yeah
you know i always tell this to um you
know aspiring
vocalists or singer songwriters um
songwriting is a totally different
you know a different thing but like when
it comes to your vocals
it's like you have to find your identity
there too yeah you know
because it's like especially for like
i mean i'm gonna poop on my own culture
but filipinos for example
um they like they love to emulate you
know they love
you know if they love me whitney houston
they're going to sound like whitney
houston if they love
um it's all about emulating and for me
it's like if you have a great voice
that's good that means you already have
the tools to control or
improve on whatever you're given or
gifted at but like you have to find your
voice in it
you know not everybody like right now
it's like
nobody needs another billy eilish you
know nobody needs another
katy perry or whatever it's like you
have to find
your identity within it you know so for
me i think
because i started off as a songwriter i
think i naturally just found how i sing
and it is what it is
like this is my range this is what i
usually do
yes there's always room for improvements
and room for
technical things that that i could
improve yeah improve on
but like i feel like i'm just very um
i'm not a very secure person i'm
insecure but i'm
very secure in that like that's the one
thing that i feel like
i can own and then like this is truly me
like the way i sing is just really
truly what my voice is you know i'm not
trying to
sing like one or two yeah and i i hear
that a lot because people oh
like it's it's really what bruno mars
did like everybody
everybody wanted to cover a bruno mars
song they wanted i was like you know he
sings in the key of a [ __ ] woman
he's a tenor yeah he's a he's a true
true
yeah there's not many voices like that i
mean that's why he's bruno right
you know the guy smokes like 30 packs of
cigarettes a day and he steals things
like that
like you don't have that voice and it's
okay you could also cover a song and
just [ __ ] lower the [ __ ] key an
octave you'll be fine
oh man capo is your friend
people don't do that they always try to
sing it it's like you don't have to you
have to find your own voice in your own
reign yeah
because if not it just sounds terrible
yeah it's like well i hit it like
technically i guess but it sounded like
trash
like yeah it's just hard for people like
i don't understand like why
it's so hard and i think it's that
karaoke mentality too
and also just because they don't have
the identity like they don't know who
they are as a singer
um you know for a casual singer i guess
it's okay but like for somebody who
wants to do it as a living or
want to pursue it more seriously i i
really do encourage people to find
who they are as a vocalist do you ever
have those awkward moments where like at
a show somebody comes up and they want
to sing to you and they're like
oh my god jeremy and gabe and i talk
about that it's like hey
can i like i just want to sing let me
just and there's just like the worst
thing
of course you're gonna say yes you don't
want to say no
i'm not you don't know me let me be a
part of the show i'm like
hey no all right they appreciate it
but no it's usually after shows or like
a meet and greet and they want to
like gather around like we want to sing
for you
thank you but no i appreciate it but
this is not the time and place thank you
so much
who is this guy you should be like our
manager
because we're all just like sure do it
sing it you should be the one that like
barges in and like no
get out like okay if you're ready to
sing are you also ready for the judgment
i'm going to translate their judgment on
to you they won't say it but i will
that was terrible good job no
surprisingly some people are really good
singers they're just you know they're
i don't know i never had that much
confidence to sing in front of the
people that i look up to you know i mean
like
and then they just i don't know it's
just a different generation like they
just want to sing in front of you i
literally
like i don't understand it but like i
appreciate it that they have that much
balls to do it i've had like kids come
up to me and they're like
he's like yo i want to show you i can
say i was like i'm a comedian
go do this to somebody else i was like i
have no
sense of judgment for your music go this
way why are you doing this for yeah i
would come back and say whatever like no
i just think it'd be really good i was
like that's great
yeah i make jokes for a living why are
you singing if i
do i like [ __ ] simon cowell to you
get the [ __ ] out of here dude
i don't i don't know maybe it's like the
need for validation i guess
i guess but you're lucky though because
literally a hundred percent have been
terrible
i i've yet to see one that was good
where i was like wow
it was always somebody who's extremely
off-key
and they just can't hear it because
they're tone deaf so i'm like you're
tone deaf man like i don't know what to
tell you like
you could tell when somebody's tone deaf
it's like oh you're tone deaf you can't
hear it yeah
it's hard you know if you're a tone deaf
like how do you train a tone deaf person
i don't know like that's like for a
vocal coach to take on like if you have
a tone-deaf
student like how do you tackle that if
you can't hear
i've always wanted to just sign up for
like stevie mackey's like online course
oh man he's amazing stevie mackey and uh
avery every wilson yeah
when i hear those two sing it's like
what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah gifted um so you said that you're a
church boy
yeah did you ever listen to like take
six
yes okay so want me to blow your mind a
little bit yeah so two of them are
cousins
really what the [ __ ] so you just have
this in your family
that's crazy yeah so uh mark kibble
who's one of the founders
live in nashville and i just you know
spent father's day with him you know
it's just like with his family it's
it's just it's really cool like and they
wanted you to be a nurse like what the
[ __ ]
like your family my filipino family
wanted me to be a nurse yeah it's like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about like
it's in my blood i got to do this
yeah so it's it's kind of cool like i
have this kind of
connection with them and it's funny
because take six gets like
um sampled quite a bit like in hip-hop
and like jay-z and kanye and all that
i'm like
how [ __ ] random random yeah that's
insane yeah
does nobody know this about you no it's
not something i put out but it's
it's funny because people look at when i
when i actually share this to people
which i also told mark um so we're
related through in-laws like
one of my aunts married to the family
and i never like made a connection with
them because just because they're my
cousins right i wanted to kind of you
know
earn my way through yeah um but
uh mark is like a huge fan of supportive
of my work and
he just loves my the way i write and
hopefully maybe we can
you know do something together but um
whenever i share the information to
to a few folks they look at me weird
it's like
wait are they part filipino yeah and
then so i just kind of mess with their
heads like no i'm part black guys
can i just leave that's [ __ ]
hilarious yeah so it's just like i i
share this with mark and
he was laughing his ass off because it's
like yeah it's it's just funny how like
um you know weird connections and
familial
thing but it's people like him like um
it wasn't that long ago that i i visited
nashville it's like couple like a month
ago
and visiting him was another kind of
reminder
for me because i had a tough year you
know i lost my dad
in october oh wow yeah not through
covington i think
i was like but but he uh he passed away
you know stroke and it was sudden and
you know i've had i'm having to deal
that with my family at the moment and
you know it's to the point that it kind
of clouded my
what's the meaning of life what am i
doing what the hell am i doing you know
grief messes with you and it wasn't uh
so this is like my first venture out
back to the studio back to like my usual
grind as a musician and
you know and i visited nashville a month
ago and you know visiting with him was
definitely a reminder of like very
encouraging and just kind of
centered me a little bit that like okay
i'm supposed to do this yeah yeah you
know and sometimes you just need those
kinds of moments
and as as a creative you're a creative
and you get really often times we just
get
so engulfed with the hustle and you know
what to do next with
whatever platforms that we deal with and
whatever pressures that we deal with but
it's like
again it whatever centers you like at
the at the end of it all what is
your goal and what is your purpose and
sometimes you just need to connect and
plug in
back to that whole thing yeah um so
yeah that was um anyways i just wanted
to share that
so your father had a stroke yeah
massive stroke it was just in the middle
of the night it was on a friday night
well technically saturday morning
um and then he got careflighted to
you know a unit a brain unit and
pretty much you know was it sudden
pretty sudden
i mean he had heart issues before
then but like he was very good with his
health after that
and his heart was actually okay you know
the the involuntary part of your brain
was the last thing to go so he was
breathing and his heart was
was was okay but his brain
activity was completely gone so the
frontal lobe was completely
oh [ __ ] that's pretty severe severe so
so you know we had eventually we had to
decide to pull the intubation
oh man it was one of those really sudden
things and
it was just hard and you know i was
pretty close to my dad
um you know he was an engineer a very
philosophical dude very uh kind of out
of the box thinker and i think
i kind of got that from him in a way um
yeah and he did he was one of those guys
that
he knew i wasn't going to be a nurse but
if anything he probably saw me as like
an architect or
or an engineer which i actually would
have been down to do
but um so he didn't quite understand
like the music
part of me initially but i think
early on in my career i did a concert
and when he saw me he was like okay yeah
this is what you're meant to do yeah so
it was um
so my dad wasn't really the most
expressive dude but
um he was just the dude guy that like
i knew he loved me i never had he never
had to show me you know kind of thing
he's just very steadfast and
anyways i call him like he's my buddy
whenever i'm at home in texas you know
whenever i
run errands he's always just i want to
go with you yeah
so um yeah it was pretty sudden and i
you know
um it happened in october my birthday's
november then christmas
and new year's of course yeah it's it's
and then
father's day in june my parents
anniversary in june as well so it's like
there's a lot of things that's going on
and
at the same time i'm trying to move
forward with my life and like
i need to create music i need to you
know all that stuff's going on
right now i mean it's it's crazy too
it's like
you know when we get older too like i i
never really thought about death as much
until
you get older right yeah and even for me
now like if i die i'm okay
but i but it's everybody else around me
that kind of messes me up emotionally
yeah
like i'm not ready to see other people
die in front of me but i'm okay to die
you know it's like yeah we don't i i
feel the same way too i'm not very
outright in saying that but like if i
die tomorrow it's like huh
you know i i did the best i could it's
fine yeah but obviously i would think
about my
my family and they would be sad and
stuff but yeah
it's it's really you know i've had
family members
pass away but to have a parent pass away
is like another level
you know i think it's almost like i'm in
my 30s but like you almost feel like an
orphan
you know yeah like being out here in l.a
was like
the first trip in my head that like i'm
moving
through these spaces knowing that my dad
isn't around anymore
yeah so it's like it messes with your
head and i have to kind of
you know let it go and like process it
as i'm
still trying to be functional i mean in
your 30s you're not expecting to lose
your parents
no no it's like they still have so much
life ahead of them and yeah when that
part's taken away from you suddenly you
how do you compartmentalize these
emotions
how do you deal with these emotions
because you weren't prepped for this
yeah like even for me
so i was really close to my grandmother
right so my grandmother raised
me for a fat chunk of my life because my
parents were always at work
so even after being able to
so while she was like in hospice care
like she had to get fed through a tube
through her stomach yeah she wasn't very
she wasn't functioning she had severe
alzheimer's she couldn't remember
anybody
well she was in hospice care like that
for about like a year and a half or so
and because my parents don't speak
english very well i had to take care of
her while she was in hospital
all the time well it was hard for that
whole year and a half that she was there
when she passed away there wasn't as
much tears because we were prepped for
it
yeah this was going to happen yeah so
it's a different feeling you know if i
didn't have that
if i didn't have that whole year and a
half to cry it out and feel this pain
i would have been wrecked you know yeah
it's i mean
death never really comes at a perfect or
a good time anyway
but uh the only con like consolation
that i do have is that
he passed away while i was in quarantine
with a family like i was actually in
town because otherwise i probably would
have been on tour
other than another city and like some
session somewhere and i probably would
get a call from home but
in a way as much as that was a lot of
suffering and a lot of trauma
almost ptsd thing because you know it
happened on a friday he passed away
officially on a sunday like every friday
saturday sunday i would have like these
these weird like anxiety episodes
and then come monday it's like gone it's
like a weird phenomenon
of trauma yeah yeah um so now it's kind
of
not there as much but i had to really
deal with that but
yeah it's it's it's it's a thing you
know i've heard this thing too from
somebody else where when they lose
somebody very close to them
that they start to feel guilt for not
feeling the same intense feelings that
they had when they first passed
because they feel like they're
forgetting them so they kind of
force themselves to relive this trauma
all the time because it makes them feel
like they're not forgetting
yeah the person that was close to them
yeah so it's like oh
well if i feel better you feel guilty
for feeling better that day
because it reminds you that you're not
thinking about the person who just
passed away
which which is [ __ ] nuts like i
didn't even think about [ __ ] like that
you know
yeah it's it's you know everybody
grieves differently you know even in my
own family they're grieving
in different ways and um you know and
again
back to music it's like it's been such a
saving grace for me
you know it's like this is something
that i
not only a distraction but something
that i can process life with even if i'm
not writing about my grief you know even
if i'm writing
as a matter of fact the song that one of
the songs that i wrote last week
is just like wanting to write a song
about cruising
down a highway you know it's like very
kind of surface but it's a fun track
but even with that it's just like i felt
like it was a healing process just to
create something
you know so i think music is much more
than like
a hobby that probably a lot of my family
members probably thought
at the beginning yeah yeah um yeah so
it's again it's just reinforces my
i guess my belief that this is what i'm
supposed to do
for however long i'm allotted to do i
mean that's the great thing right
there's no really like
there's no like expiration on it no yeah
and you know what's funny
i thought there was an expiration
because you know the societal thing like
by the time you're 27 you're out yeah
you know
it's um you know
you emphasize youth right kids being
like the number one um
[Music]
charting artists right now and back then
right
and they just don't value like wisdom
yeah that's the word
they don't value wisdom and knowledge
and experience
as i'm talking about the bigger in this
music industry
but i think that's the beauty of like
how we came up you know like with
youtube
and like independent artistry and like
you know smaller venues who host
smaller artists um
or independent artists it's like you
know we're in an age as much as like
there are some cons about internet and
social media and all that stuff i think
there's also like the upside
i wouldn't exist with that social media
yeah none of us would like
i definitely wouldn't be here as much as
we complain so much about it because we
know
like the the crazy parts and like the
grind
it's i'm still very thankful for it and
because i wouldn't
i wouldn't be doing what i'm doing yeah
it was
like i said like our purpose was so
different too it was just to share a
piece of us
yeah and that's and whatever happened
from it happened from it yeah and it was
such a crazy experience like the
the idea of expecting nothing and
getting everything
yeah how nuts is that yeah i mean i
wouldn't have
thought that like i would be touring
with india ari
i would have thought that like i would
write a song with her i mean
it's it's funny because she even did
like an igtv blog right
and she was talking about the qualm her
her
i don't know like she hates music
industry and how he
not hates but she she doesn't like it
she's not completely independent
she she parted ways with her motown i
guess record label
and she would talk about like you know
the struggles of being female and being
black and being a minority and then she
would talk about all these other artists
about like
you should check out these artists and
like she talked she mentioned me
and she was like you should listen to
melissa palinar you're one of my good
friends and she's
world class and if you don't know her
just
that just means it's because the music
industry just
sucks you know that's what she told
she told her fans and and it's like
somebody like her
who has like so much belief in what i do
it's just like
like i did something right you know in a
way
[Music]
there's something about you the way you
move the way you look
at me
[Music]
there's something about the way you see
things it's like a change
of scenery
everything about you i
just want more
[Music]
but don't get any closer
if this will last a little longer
there's a chance i find myself saying
there's nothing nothing i can do
to keep my heart away from you i can't
help it i can't tell you what to try
[Music]
cause whenever you knee
[Music]
it's love that i fear
been safe in the shell and i can't tell
if i'm living
at all
i've been doing well on my own but
maybe it's just me who i'm deceiving
cause everything about me leads
right to you
[Music]
oh i want to get closer
but let me doubt a little longer
till i turn it over thank giving cause
there's
nothing nothing i can do
to keep my heart away from you i can't
help it i can't tell you what to try
to get you off my mind to
help
[Music]
[Music]
it's love that i feel
falling so well placely
fear of losing losing
control
[Music]
nothing i can do to keep my heart away
from you
i can't help it i can't tell you what to
try
to get you off my mind to
help me move on and just live my life i
can't
help it i can't tell you how much it's
right
cause whenever you're near
it's love that i
fear
of affirmation it's weird you know but
that's what i'm saying
like goes back to like the whole purpose
thing yeah what
what really means a lot to us right so
we could have the uh
like temporary adoration of like a
million people
yeah versus somebody that we really look
up to yes
like i would take that one person any
day yeah right
i would i would say so yeah it feels
different yeah i'm not talking about
fans like fans are different i'm talking
about just random people that come
through you know
there's there's a difference in that
right so like when
like somebody like a buddy of mine asked
because they're on the youtube space and
they're very popular right and they go
oh how did you get invited by this
comment how come this comic knows you
it's like because they [ __ ] with my
stuff
yeah you know and there's fans of your
stuff yeah it's a weird it's a weird
conversation to have because of like
what the [ __ ] they like it's like i love
them like they never hit me up it's like
because they don't like your [ __ ]
like that's what it is pretty much yeah
like they're already established they
don't
need your [ __ ] influence they're just
looking at content
it's like why do you think they asked me
back to come back on their podcast why
do you think they're asking me when i'm
going to do stand-up
it's because they like what i do this is
important to me i can't trade that
experience off yeah
i mean you have to be motivated in a
deeper level for sure yeah
you know and sometimes it's easier to be
motivated by like
you know popularity and all that stuff
which i'm not against
of course it's so nice to be popular for
the things that you care about
yeah that's what that's where it's going
to feel really good yeah
you know i'm everybody's different like
i i've learned now to understand that
people have different motivators you
know
like when people say like oh i'm
motivated by money cool that's you
that's
yeah that's okay too or fame yeah if
that's what gets you to wake up in the
morning and that's what drives you i can
have an opinion about the longevity of
that or not but
this is what you live for then you can't
live for the things that i live for yeah
that's just
is what it is yeah but i think it's hard
for people to see that other people have
different motivating factors
and when they we don't fit into that
mold they start to to kind of categorize
us as whether we're successful or a
failure it's like based on who yeah
and that's another thing too how do you
define success you know
it's like and i've had to kind of define
it in a
different way now and i
it's not very concrete i mean
what is success though like you're i
find you highly successful like you made
music that impacts people's lives
as a songwriter as a musician what what
more is there yeah
what more is there but you know it's
like you know being a creative sometimes
you're very self-deprecating and i've
had to
even my therapist would say you need to
be more self-compassionate melissa i'm
like
okay i'mma try yeah yeah yeah
but yeah that's the struggle you know i
uh because it's like
also two i'm not very competitive by the
way but i am however very hard on myself
like i read a good song cool
now beat that but that's why you create
great art though
if you didn't have that how would you
create great art yeah if you're not
looking to kind of progress because
everybody does that too and people like
hey do you ever look at your old videos
think is i think everything i've done in
the back
is trash because i always feel like i
could do better yeah minus a few
sketches where i'm like this is the best
thing i've ever done in my life
you know this is [ __ ] basketball
commercial that is like a fake nike
commercial
i still watch my own video and i laugh
i'm like this is hilarious like
there's a few of them like moments yeah
yeah yeah but like i'm pretty sure when
you look at some of your work
like some of them you're like yeah
whatever yeah but then that's not how
everybody else feels about
it the effect was there yeah which is
crazy like i'm saying like
songwriting for anybody who wants to try
it it's a difficult thing to do
it's not easy you know you write a song
you still have to produce it
and a pre if you pick the wrong producer
they'll
botch it that's the hard part finding a
producer like people that you work with
and on top on top of that too if you
don't know how to like
mix your own [ __ ] finding a sound
engineer to [ __ ] mix your vocals
correctly the way you want it to it's
completely different it's everything
it's not only the producer but the mind
and it's also like
what kind of drummer what kind of
guitarist if you
need one what kind of bassist because
every person
um like for example every bassist is
different their swag is different you
know like if you're
if you want an r b track you need an r b
bassist
you can't have a pop rock bassist i mean
there's some basses who are just very
like versatile and all that stuff but
you know you you have to be very
strategic and
like how you want to build the track and
how you want to record it
and again whenever you record it matters
what mic you record it
doesn't better everything matters what
pre-amps you're gonna use like
it's all different like the warmth like
people don't understand too when you
record on different mics there's a
different
warmth to it yeah and it takes
differently like my voice will take
differently from
with a certain mic then your voice will
take on a certain mic you know it's
because everybody's just different yeah
yeah a lot of [ __ ] belters love using
these mics right here these are
yeah because this is uh michael
jackson's favorite yeah
everybody who [ __ ] belts that out
they [ __ ] love this microphone
recording i would never use
to record my vocals yeah me too um yeah
i use uh my favorite would have to be
like a you
87. because they're still warm though
those are so warm when you record it
yeah and then like there's a mic
microphone called the manly manly mics
m-e-m-a-n-l-e-y
and you know there's some you know these
are kind of like the nerdy talks now but
like you learn that stuff as you go you
know i didn't know all that stuff when i
started but
i didn't know any of that [ __ ] because i
you know when we record like these
covers like
we don't prep anything yeah cause i'm
just like hey i just want to come in and
i kind of know this song and then we
record it
30 minutes and i leave but then you know
when we started recording at different
people's studios
i was like why does my voice vocal sound
so different yeah right preamps
different
preamps different the mic is different
and i'm like oh i hate this mic yep
i hate like blue microphones i'm not a
big fan of them at all i do not like
them
somehow blue microphones don't really
like my voice for some reason
i don't think i think they're made for a
lot of pop vocals yeah like
anything with like r b that requires
like like like a bigger
it just doesn't sound [ __ ] good but
you have like people who have thin poppy
voices
yeah perfectly fine yeah yeah because i
i um
i've worked with several producers who
do like this kind of like
test mic on me so they would like
install like
set up five mics at a time and i would
sing the same line
and then they would judge which mic
would would work best for me and those
are fun
but um yeah and sometimes on occasion
the cheaper mics like my voice it's all
different
so it's just like it's not about how
expensive it is it's just how
it takes your voice and how it can
handle like certain frequencies and
stuff so
yeah there's all this like and people
don't understand how hard it is to
create music like
yeah especially when i believe like the
way that you create music is very vocal
heavy
right yeah yeah so it requires
that part to be real there's no there's
nothing else really covering it
you know it's just your vocals yeah and
then obviously there's a melody but then
you know from what i've heard from your
music it's not going to be high
production that becomes like the main
attraction of the song
it's the lyrics and the vocals yeah so
that part is very [ __ ] important
yeah you know i mean it's it's fun i
mean i've i've
a lot of what i've released and shared
with the world are very like acoustic or
very singer songwriter vibe
but like yeah i mean i am even
interested in doing
to stretch my um i don't know
sound and all that stuff not necessarily
for my artistry but just for writing
because create
creativity is fun yeah you know so it's
uh
i was so shocked when like something
random like [ __ ] um
because you know kesha she's super pop
she was a writer before she was a
[ __ ]
you know so is bruno a lot of people
yeah bruno was writing music for
everybody for years yeah and then he was
put into the spotlight but you know
somebody like kesha that all this bimbo
is like you don't know her [ __ ]
catalog though
she's been doing music for quite a while
yeah who else who had like a
sia same yeah she wrote for everybody
and it's to the point that like i'm so
familiar with her
phrasing this is my brain working like
there's a certain phrasing and certain
like melodic
nuances that each writer does that they
have an identity
i remember listening to a katy perry
song and i immediately said
sia wrote this and i looked up the
credits so like sure enough
you know you know what that is for me
it's [ __ ] neo oh yeah
yeah he has a significant same chord
progressions
and when i heard um the john legend song
we dance and sing song
i was like neo yeah and then you look up
the credits like
it was like right there i don't know i'm
like that's crazy like yeah i have those
kinds of like things with certain
artists or certain writers
um yeah it's kind of cool to to hear
that
and actually recognize like i think i
know who wrote that song
yeah i mean that's just the mode so what
are your like upcoming projects now
um well you know i'm just beefing up my
catalog
okay and that's a very music industry
thing to say
but uh yeah i you know this past year
i've been
um well first of all when i was
quarantined
2020 i set up my own music studio
home setup because i
had no luxury to go to studios anymore
so i had to learn all
i mean i knew the basics but i had to
learn the preamps i learned
universal audio bought a new laptop new
monitors
everything so hard it's so hard i had to
learn from scratch
you know i tried learning and i was like
i can't do this
i was like it's fun after a while it
gets fun if you you
like everything it was like learning a
new language yeah i was like i don't
know what the [ __ ]
any of this is yeah so um
what's interesting in the past year uh
besides all the
the crappy things that has happened um
i've been busy just recording i
i wasn't in a writing mode so i i didn't
force myself to write
i just like okay let's bring out some
songs that
i want i've always wanted to record and
release so the top of
the first half of this year i've
released a few that are
technically produced by me oh wow yeah
so um
uh there's this one called back to me uh
with tony luca and then um
the one with the another song called
inner me
that was co-produced with with with
jesse
because he added some production
elements but the latest one
i technically produced it um it's called
we started a song that's within the re
so we wrote that years ago but we never
did anything to it so i
reached out sometime in 2020 i said like
i would love to release this as a duet
are you down
yeah she said i would love to so i've
been
i waited for a couple months for
her to send me vocal stems and i hired
a guitarist actually her guitarist in
new york and just put all the files
together
and recorded it and had just oh not
jesse actually another guy to mix it and
a dude from the uk to master it how
[ __ ] crazy
it's weird it's just all like remote and
then yeah we released it that was like
technically my last single that i
released with indiari
yeah it's called we started a song it's
a it's kind of inspired by like joni
mitchell like
because we love joni mitchell when we
wrote the song we were like
two soulful singers love like folk
um that's crazy you have a track within
the array yeah
how [ __ ] nuts is that it's kind of
cool yeah it's it's so
kind of cool that's really cool yeah so
she's
you know she's proud of it too she loves
the song because obviously
india is the type of person if she
doesn't really like the song she will
never do it yeah
and so she was again it's a part part
because she believes in me and loves my
music
and um again so i put it all together in
my little home studio
and um [ __ ] awesome yeah it's cool
technology
and then now i guess moving forward
again like i've just been
writing you know last week i wrote with
jessie
which by the way i can let you hear
after this whole thing
um yeah it's they're all kind of rough
mixes now
and we're still deciding if i'm gonna
keep pumping out singles or put it all
in an ep together you know
those are like the strategic things that
you can think of when it comes to music
but at the moment i'm just enjoying
creativity i'm just enjoying the writing
process i'm enjoying
singing again that's awesome yeah and
then the shows
upcoming shows with jeremy and gabe and
oh yeah and he the three of us are
trying to finish our ep
that's another thing another ep it's
gonna be exciting i'm so glad like like
i get really happy when i see people who
i've like follow for so and still
continue to do stuff that they love
thanks because i think there's a lot of
external factors that
kind of cause them not to right like
i've like i've talked to certain friends
on youtube where they were
super popping when they were doing
youtube 10 years ago and all they do is
talk about their past
and it's like bro like [ __ ] let it go
man
like you're not that person anymore yeah
like hanging on to their old laurels
kind of thing yeah it's like
like who the [ __ ] cares yeah and you
know and this there's
every time it's a conversation with them
it's about who they were how popular
they were
it's like well then your heart wasn't in
the right place like yeah you were you
made music for
for everybody else but yourself and so
now you're looking for external
validation
and guess what that's a really tough way
to live yeah i mean
that would be tiring to be honest it's
exhausting
right it's like so you've never created
for yourself like you only created for
other people
yeah like how does that how is that
sustainable because people are
people are [ __ ] a fickle like they
love you one day and they [ __ ] forget
you the next
especially these days yeah it's a part
of the game so you're kind of investing
in something that you know is going to
hurt you at the end
like you can be as popular as you want
even somebody like justin bieber 30
years from now justin bieber is not
going to be justin bieber
he's going to be just oh i remember i
used to listen to a lot of his music
and he's going to have to go through
that too everybody has their time
yeah and the fact that you know some of
these people who have a conversation
with
you keep talking about something that
doesn't exist you can't grow
what is your next move yeah yeah or if
you want that recognition you got to do
stupid [ __ ] to get it if that's what
you're surviving off of
you know and you know for me music is
just
it's not necessarily only like melissa
palinar as an artist
yeah music to me is kind of whole
encompassing i could you know i could
see myself 10
5 10 years from now like you know
writing for
films and shows and and like
you know for other artists for other
people and you know
and genre wise too like people always
think of me as like soulful acoustic but
i love to write other things like i'd
write i'm down to even write country or
folk you know it's like that's awesome
i mean i think my love for music just
is is just deeper and that like i could
see myself doing it for a long
period of time you know but in different
forms
because i know i don't want to tour
yeah all the time traveling is such a
you know i'm a homebody so it's like
traveling can be very taxing
and especially now too with the you know
coveted and stuff
everything's halted but then things are
going getting back up again so there's
that pressure of like oh
let's go on the road songwriting always
lives though like people people don't
even know the [ __ ]
what's the uh uh ariana grande on
honeymoon avenue
[ __ ] babyface wrote that [ __ ] it's
like
babyface was somebody i listened to face
is my
yeah i definitely have influences
whenever you know what's funny is that
my band member is like whenever i have a
band they were like oh that's like a
baby face chord like i don't
i didn't know i did that but it's
subconscious it's amazing
that's why when i heard all the uh
[ __ ] jeremy stuff yeah i was like
you sound exactly like music soul child
his
his core choices the way his vocals yeah
very music soul child
yeah and you know it's subconscious it's
just in in
in our thing yeah like people may not
hear this and i'm not sure i haven't had
a conversation with her
but i would be far surprised if [ __ ]
tory kelly didn't listen to brandy
growing up
i think she did because her her runs are
very similar to brandy's yeah a lot so i
was like oh [ __ ]
that's why i was i gravitated toward kel
tory kelly i mean she's a great vocalist
oh yeah but
i one of my favorite female vocalists of
all time
is brandy you know what jeremy's
favorite too
by the way yeah female vocalist he we
because we talk on the road you know
when we travel and i always we always
ask these questions so who's your
favorite vocalist and
says brandy yeah brandi is up there yeah
and so when i heard her sing i was like
wow she reminds me of
brandy a lot yeah but a lot of people
don't give brandy or do credit
this is true yeah this is true i mean i
grew up watching militia
they have it all [ __ ] networks yes i
haven't i haven't watched it again yet
but yeah it's definitely like memories
and i was so happy when they put the the
cinderella
on disney yeah so that's that's
definitely a thing she was so
she was so hot and then just like we
never questioned
why an asian prince has a black and a
white
parent i know it was just what it was
before it's time
it's just like oh okay they have an
asian kid cool
i guess this works this is a fantasy
world anyway there's a growing pumpkin
who the [ __ ] cares
it just is what it is exactly well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
i hope you guys enjoyed that you can
find melissa polinar all over youtube
spotify uh instagram check out her music
one of my favorite artists of all time
and it was it was super fun
having you yeah thank you for having me
it was fun cool well genius bring
podcasts every thursday and sundays and
we'll see y'all next time
peace